[Music]
I seem fun the diary of Jen Kirkman
podcast episode I'm recording that 185
okay they don't have to know that 184 is
being recorded after this one who cares
this is a listener email episode I
answer all your questions and problems
have a lot of freaky listeners it should
be some good stuff subscribe on iTunes
okay
of course I print it out like 50 pages
and I didn't they're not numbered so
just hold please while I do this yeah I
have a lot of listener emails perfect
okay just wanted to make sure okay
let's do it let's do it let's do it
let's do this alright listener emails
that's this okay yeah so I didn't I
don't know what I did wrong I don't know
what I did wrong
but I was so like look how organized I
am Erin I'm back into all things comedy
studio go to all things comedy comm for
all of your podcast needs there are so
many great podcasts on the network just
make sure I'm still your favorite to
listen to all the other ones send me an
email I seem fun at gmail.com and always
doing those listener email episodes I
love to do them you can send me
something you want me to talk about you
can ask me a question you can share
something the podcast started with the
concept of tell me what you think it's
fun that other people don't find fun and
vice versa and go to the Facebook page
for I seem fun every episode is listed
with details sometimes there's fun
videos
that's facebook.com slash I seems fun
podcasts follow the podcasts on Twitter
at I seem fun podcast and if you want to
tell your friends about I seem fun there
is the first ever I seem fun best of
episode it just came out a couple weeks
ago they can find that on iTunes go to
iTunes give this show 5 stars
and even if you don't listen on itunes
when you subscribe on iTunes I've been
I'm not in the top 100 I used to be in
the top 100 all the time and then I
looked the other day I'm not even in the
top 200 and there's some [ __ ] ass
podcasts in it and so I don't know do
you know why people get into this is
Aaron and I'm just going to with my
problems now generally speaking newer
shows will get ranked higher because
they are acquiring subscribers at a
faster rate than people who have been
around right so it's like new reviews
because they've been around oh it's the
number of people that subscribe that
week new subscribers and in reviews okay
so guys give me a review you motherfucks
the only problem with that too is if
you've already written review you can't
write a new one
okay well tell them to open a new
account provide open and new now tell
your friends to write a review I bet
listen climate every I've never written
a review of a podcast I like here's what
I would do you have a friend who have an
iPhone grab it subscribe to I seem fun
on their phone and then just put it back
what all right I love it it's very
covert watch all angry emails coming
when I say [ __ ] alright well listen I
printed out all these emails and now I
can't [ __ ] really understand what I
did here we go let's just start okay or
someone okay look a long time ago I
think it was 2010 or 11 I went on my
friend Jackie Cashion's podcast the dork
force and I had our friend Karen Ron
Kowski read my tarot cards and I wasn't
being honest at the time about what I
wanted to ask about because it was very
private and so I was just like I don't
know you tell me what you see and this
guy like basically transcribed the
reading and everything has happened and
but I don't have time it's good kind of
boring to read but it wasn't it was not
boring for me to read so thank you sir
but I'm going to have to find a way to
condense it but today is not that day
but he did say as an icing funner o-p-s
between you and me I work at BevMo
offering Jen Kirkman approved non
customer harassing customer service just
being straight-up helpful as needed
which I know you've mentioned a handful
of times I wanted to let you know in
regards to your love of matches
but I don't know about the Southern
California stores but here in Northern
California
we give matches out with the cigars we
sell so most cashiers have a big box
that strike on box matches on hand Wow
does a fancy cut even if they weren't
buying a cigar I've never turned down
someone asking for a box of matches or
to alternate alternatively if you don't
want to be someone who's just mooching
matches apropos of nothing most stores
have birthday candles for sale and lots
of cashiers are happy to provide a box
of matches with those two that's a hot
take thank you everybody
all right these are deep there's like
talk about God someone's mom is abusive
I mean I don't know I don't know where
the fun ones are let's just go deep
let's just of you people can handle it
it's almost summer everyone else will be
like oh my god fun stuff but not here
and I seem fun here and I seem fun we're
going to go deep okay high school in the
south hey Jen I've been a fan for a
while and was blessed well that's a
sweet thing to say it actually sounds
sincere not like hashtag blessed to find
out you had an entire podcast for me to
laugh and vibe with Oh
oh my god it's printed this all I
printed the wrong ah-oh but have it on
my computer you know what guys look it I
did it wrong okay but I brought my
[ __ ] computer I know you're like why
would anyone listen to the podcast I
don't [ __ ] know but here's why
because that was so charming alright I'm
going to go to my listener emails I seem
fun listen your email episodes Oh whoo
okay here we go
hi Jen this person has been rejected by
a college I know you're not running an
advice column no certainly not
but I like how you view the world and
I'd love your opinion I got wait-listed
after being rejected once by the school
I want to go to I'm in Community College
and living at home with my mom so not
the ideal situation they put idea
situation but
I get what you mean why were you
rejected from a school I wonder just
kidding that was a [ __ ] move I feel
like there's a large chance that I won't
get off the waitlist so I'm wondering if
I should even wait around to find out
I've been waiting to find out since
February 3rd and now won't know until
July living in limbo is making me crazy
I need a plan what would you do I don't
spend so long since I've gone to college
I don't even remember how this [ __ ]
works so you got wait-listed after
you're rejected once and that's the
school you want to go to okay
to live not that long I know it took me
a while to get to this email but July is
not that long if this is what you really
want you can wait you're living with
your mom I'm sure it's not ideal are you
paying a ton of bills no Community
College is just fine you're getting some
learning on just do what you love
whatever I don't know what you're
majoring in or what the school is all
about that you want to be in but
whatever the reason you want to go to
the school for just read books on that
in your spare time and just July is not
a long time if you are wait-listed again
in July then I don't know is there
another school you want to apply to or
is it just that one I mean I would just
keep applying to colleges until you get
into one that you want to go to and if
it just comes down to like no one will
take you and it's only Community College
I would just do that and try to get your
own place eventually but I don't know
anything about Community College can you
go to Community College in a different
City like if I live in Boston can I go
to a community college in Denver
Colorado
I think find out that and then move or
you want to move but I really I mean I
can't be this helpful because I don't
even know what the [ __ ] is happening all
right someone talks about oh god it's
okay when to bring up no kids on a date
hey Jen feel free to use my name on air
I didn't include it nothing anyway I'm a
30 year old single guy and I'm fairly
confident I'll never want to have kids
I've only ever really had one long-term
relationship three years that ended four
and a half years ago seems normal for
your age mainly because she wanted kids
and I did
I wasn't sure if I would change my mind
on that down the road so we decided to
end the relationship I've had a couple
shorter flings two to three months max
but nothing really serious outside of
that my question is when in your opinion
is the right time to bring up with
someone you are dating that you don't
want kids would you just want to state
it on the first date wait until you
define the relationship flash become
exclusive or some other time I certainly
don't want to wait until we're like a
year into it to bring it up or anything
like that but I also worry bringing it
up on the first date might be a bit much
ah you know I have no idea because I I
don't I don't know what the dating thing
is like like I'm just like oh hi I'm in
a relationship so it's like I in the
past anyone I've dated has been from my
comedy community and I've been talking
about how I don't want kids since I
started in comedy so if I dated other
comedians they knew because they saw it
so there's really never been Wenders
there was any one out of the blue that
wasn't somehow aware of my material
about that trying to think trying to
think no no
so I don't know I don't know but here's
what I would do because here's the thing
and I don't mean to be like ginger mind
but you're a guy so you can change your
mind if that makes sense
because you can have kids till your
sperm runs out or whatever look at a
look at all these great men who decide
to have a baby at 65 with their 20 year
old girlfriend what a great deal for the
kid you know oh my dad might die before
I graduate high school so anyway I think
parents selfishly think Oh at least I'll
be there for my kids formative years
it's like but will you because you'll be
elderly and then they don't want a
parent that's dead it 20 I don't know
but usually these people are famous and
rich so it's a who knows it's not like
like you know I mean like I'm yeah
you're not going to have to clean out
your parents house by yourself at age 19
if you're like Alec Baldwin's kid or
whatever all right
so here's what I would do I would do you
use like a tinder account or something
because maybe you can put that in your
bio like in a funny way like I don't
want kids and maybe you'll meet other
people who don't want kids because I
feel like people who know they don't
want kids know what they want to do
besides have a kid like they might be
more prone to traveling or doing certain
things so maybe in a joking way if
you're on any of the apps as I say I
don't know if you can put a bio on them
but maybe do that the other thing I
would say is yeah because what if you
like let's just say this let's say you a
couple dates with someone but you don't
know that this is like the one and maybe
she wants kids but she'll love you so
much that she's like oh you know what I
actually don't need them like she might
change her mind and you guys might be
the love of each other's life and or
maybe you will decide like when you're
50 that you're like I you know what I
think I would do it I don't want to lose
her like so I feel like if it's a woman
I would say always be up front right
away that you're looking for someone to
make a baby with because you don't have
a lot of time but since you're a guy
it's like well you know I wouldn't waste
anyone's time if someone says if someone
else brings it up on the first date I
really want kids you can say you know
what I've had a relationship and over
this I really don't want them but if you
want to date me until you find the guy
who does like let's have fun or whatever
I mean I feel like you just hang out
with a person see how much you like them
and worry about it later but don't lie
about it or be vague I mean I feel like
these are the conversations people have
any way like just philosophically like
you want kids someday no woman is not
going to ask you that I think I don't
know but yeah I wouldn't jump into it
because you know why also I have to tell
you I've never I've dated a few guys
that realized they wanted kids and one
guy who wasn't sure and so one of them
who wanted kids has them and the guy
that wasn't sure doesn't but I wasn't
sure wasn't enough for me and so but the
guys I've met that are like super
against kids that talk about it right
away have always been kind of like
failing in other areas of life too like
I feel like I keep going in and out you
can hear me though right yeah those
headphones are a little problem okay
so I've always feel like you know like I
don't know you know what I'm saying like
with someone I met once was like I don't
believe in money I'm like okay well
that's the currency we currently use and
do you think you don't believe in it
because you don't make any and I don't
mean enough I mean zero dollars a year
so you gotta be careful you know you're
going to weed those people out that is
less to you and to me to my old self
okay all right this one is a doozy her
sister is in love with a prisoner hello
Jen I would like your opinion on
something that has come up my sister
older by two years started a pen pal
type correspondence with a prisoner it
started out as an outreach to specific
types of prisoners who are interested in
religion okay sorry I lost my place the
prisoners have to get recommended by
another prisoner who has been in the
program you know Charlie here I've
killed two people Charlie's killed one I
think Charlie would be a great candidate
I love it the other people vouching for
him is another prisoner like oh okay oh
so the rapist you stabbed his cousin he
said he recommends you walk his his word
is gold
no I'm kidding I know people are
reformed and not everyone in prison
raped someone instead they're ghosts
okay she was told this about a co-worker
of hers back in October is when they
started writing to each other and it was
very businesslike and they only talked
about his soul I think it was very
businesslike I don't really do the whole
religion thing we were raised Catholic
and she has recently really gotten
involved in the church but I've kept a
small distance and everything anyway
basically I'm pretty sure they stuck to
him finding out about Catholicism and
stuff like that okay
around the end of January beginning of
February she started getting calls from
him and she would talk
about him more and more in a more
personal way she told me at the end of
February that she was starting to like
him and that they talked at least once a
day over the phone and wrote to each
other just as often
alright I'm having so many thoughts okay
only thing he did you okay I and she
talked her more no more she told me the
end of February that she was starting to
like him and that they talked at least
once a day over the phone and wrote to
each other just as often he is in prison
in Texas for grand theft with a deadly
weapon all right he has been in prison
since he was 15 no I say no already I'll
tell you why
and his 25 his total sentence is 18
years but could get released early for
good behavior okay no no no I have a
feeling by now you have had so many
opinions and probably think my sister
needs help so wait there's more he is
also technically an illegal immigrant he
came to the US when he was about 10 she
is afraid that when he gets out
ice will be waiting for him to take him
back to Guatemala and she will never see
him it's possible she wants to get a
lawyer to help him no no and possibly if
it comes to it marry him no that's the
game he's playing sister that's the game
he's playing and if he's not playing it
so don't marry him I have voted my
opinion as much as I can
voiced but I have run out of things to
say at this point in their relationship
they call themselves boyfriend and
girlfriend and say I love you when they
get off the phone she talks to him so
much now it almost goes up to three
times a day for hours at a time she is
in therapy feel like you might ask that
I don't know if she has talked about
this with her therapist and if she has I
don't know what the therapist is said
about it yeah the problem with therapy
is you only have an hour a week and it
takes a long time because the therapist
doesn't give advice they let you come to
your own conclusions whereas if you go
to JK I'll tell you exactly what she
should do and she's not going to do it
and you're going to have to get yourself
a book about codependency but we'll get
to you later
I don't know she has talked about the
circuit therapist and if she has I don't
know what the therapist is said about it
I have never talked to him on the phone
but have been near her when she was been
talking to him
he seems like a nice person that got
caught up in gang life at an early age
and is now paying for that but I don't
really know
I have even told her that if she took
the prisoner part out of the equation it
would still be weird that she was
talking to some guy in Texas I agree
that's a good point my opinion I have
two conflicting opinions my first one is
that I'm so happy that she has found
someone what he wants okay I have to
read it as you wrote it because I can't
understand is that I am so happy that he
has found what he wants in his religion
and that he has someone to talk to my
second and most important is she's my
sweet gullible big sister who is being
taken advantage of and it's going to get
cheated out of her money and love sorry
this is so long but it's a lot to think
about well let me know what you think
I'd like to say an anonymous oh I'd like
to stay anonymous thank you like her
sister would be listening to this like
whatever your name is Sally there's
someone else you know that podcast you
love some other listener has a sister
who's has the same exact prison love
life that I do alright here's the deal I
don't know how old you people are that's
the problem
this guy's 25 holds your sister if she's
older than him know it she's his age no
just get our whole life ahead of her
here's the deal and I'm not saying this
in a negative way religion especially
when you're new to it can give you a
high it's a wonderful feeling to
surrender your sense of that you don't
control the universe to something and it
can be really lovely and especially when
you have other people that share your
views it's really bonding now wouldn't
you say well that's what you would want
in a relationship as someone that shares
your values absolutely but both of them
are high right now this is drama this is
love drama
this is unreality and trust me
a long-distance relationship and it's
the same thing you just don't know
someone until you really know them and
you can talk on the phone all you want
but she has no idea what this guy is
like in real life and let's just take
everything anybody's totally reformed
he's never going to grand theft whatever
again he has not just been I'm going to
the grocery store here's me at Christmas
like there is they are making these big
decisions that people who are physically
around each other make after years right
you don't just talk about getting
married after three months and to marry
someone for anything like oh they need
to stay in the country no this guy might
not even know he's being manipulative
but it might just be in his blood he's
probably so in love with the fact that
maybe someone can save him he doesn't
know how to take care of himself he's a
prisoner he was in prison since age 15
that's the mental age that he still is
unfortunately and they say when you're a
drug user if you use drugs as a teenager
even if you get sober all this a lot of
things in your life you are still a
teenager about them because that was the
last time you that was when you started
stunting your development so his
development is stunted and she's not
giving herself a chance and no prisoners
deserve love let him get out of prison
and find love with someone who
understands him she should be if she's
really involved in the church I mean duh
don't you think that's where you meet a
guy I mean I know maybe they're all
married or in the closet but there's got
to be one nice guy at the church I don't
know what kind of church this is you
said Catholic but I know it is it oh
yeah okay sometimes not like
Episcopalian not that that matters
here's what I would do if I were you now
I see here's the details that I would
ask you do you guys live together
why are you if you don't live with your
sister well it doesn't matter if you
live with her not but I could see if you
live with her that this is annoying
because you have to be around it all the
time but um I would say
that you need to let her make her own
mistakes you can't stop her and while I
think that your first opinion you don't
have two conflicting opinions you have
one opinion that she's you're gullible
sister who's being taken advantage of
and is going to get cheated out of her
money and love that's your opinion the
fact that you're happy that he found
religion and has someone to talk to
that's not your opinion of this
situation that's your feeling about him
and that's lovely but your opinion of
the situation is is that you have one
opinion not two conflicting there's a
world where a lovely man in prison
it loves your sister but you don't want
them to be together I don't even think
you have to worry about she's being
taken advantage of and getting it
cheated I don't think you need to tell
her that I think the other things I said
is like why you know what is it in her
psyche that's making her want to fall in
love with a prisoner there's intimacy
issues if she doesn't want she wants
something she can control I mean this is
like some woman's dream which is like
she gets to live the life she wants and
then she gets to have the romance of
talking to someone every day but she's
not really living a life with him and
she has no idea what he's going to be
like with her once he gets out right now
he's in prison he doesn't have anything
else to do she has his full attention
he's probably not going to cheat on her
you know he's not going to she has no
idea what she's going to be like when he
gets out if he feels he was locked up
during his good years is he going to
want to [ __ ] a million people when he
gets out I mean that's my first thought
and eighteen years I mean no even if he
gets out on good behavior it's still a
couple years from now right because he's
25 he's been in for ten I'm sure he's
great and totally reformed but I just
don't think you need to date someone
who's currently in prison if they'd had
that in their past I would not be so
like know about it but I wrote no no no
times 15 when I was listening so and it
doesn't matter if she's talking to her
therapist a therapist can't really be
like don't do it but if I were you I
would check out a book
called clean hmm hang on
because even if you don't think you're
codependent on your sister which means
like you just want her to change which
she's doing maybe just read a book by
p.m. Elodie called
facing codependence what it what it is
where it comes from and how it sabotages
our lives and just read it
because even if you aren't a classified
codependent we all have moments in our
lives where we are obsessed with getting
someone out of a situation they're in
and we cannot stop them we have to learn
to detach with love and keep ourselves
sane so I would just read that if I were
you because I don't think you can worry
about this another second because she is
going to do it she is going to do
someone like her who's obviously looking
for something right she's in therapy
she's found religion
she's obviously searching she's not
gonna listen to you right now but I
think that you should make very clear to
yourself that you've done all you can
okay great alright this person Oh
another person about no kids alright
let's just stay on that let's just stay
on the topic mmm let's just go back to
this this is Kevin and listen to icing
fund since episode 3 was released
you've mentioned many self-help books
and a few personally to me because of
this I was wondering if you could
recommend any more self-help books on
any subject good luck Kevin well sure I
mean I read a lot I probably won't tell
you guys about but it just depends on
what angle you want to go at it from I
mean there's always Louise hey you can
heal your life that's like a little
spiritual whatever you know like if you
have a cold what's your sore throat
really saying Marion Williamson's return
to love these are all like the super
spiritual hippie tips
I'm currently reading I was on this
podcast called 10% happier which is a
really great podcast it's the news
anchor on I think he's on Good Morning
America weekend dan Harris and he was
you know it wasn't even supposed to do
the drinking in the cocaine but he was
like living it up but not really
partying like more of a weekend warrior
who was just like I must win at life and
he started having panic attacks on air
and all this stuff and he got into
meditation and his book is written so
well because it's like oh this is stupid
it's like it's everything you would
think it's called 10% happier how I
tamed the voice in my head and he's
great and it's not religious he's Jewish
but it's like about mindfulness
meditation and it's such a good read
it's just like a great bio too
so I would read that because there's a
lot of self-help in it he has all these
great therapists and you know like
advisers he's talked to you and and it's
real down-to-earth and it's really good
I think you would love it you know I'm a
big fan of the panic attack workbook
that's another one I'm not really into
self-help books to be honest with you
I'm more I work some spiritual programs
but that's so personal I feel like it's
different for everyone
but if you pee a metal melody p.m.
melody always has good books like she
writes about codependency and intimacy
issues so if you just google her name in
Amazon you could find anything I enjoy
you know like Wayne Dyer I mean he's
dead now and feel like he was kind of a
bullshitter but I don't like anything
that's like I'm manifesting and I'm this
in that I like more he's got a good book
change your thoughts change your life
living the wisdom of the DAO you know
t8o so if you're not going to read the
daodejing
you can read his interpretation of it
which is really good and all these stuff
all these stuff is a I think really what
self-help is all about I know that there
are some other self-help books I like
you know there's like I guess there's
this new one everyone loves called make
your bed it's a best-seller I haven't
read it I can't
I can't uh I can't recommend it but you
know I really think for me it's like
anything that's sort of you know who I
love to is jack Kornfield he's a major
he's got no time like the present
finding freedom love and joy right where
you are I think that's coming out later
he's a mindful co-founded the Insight
Meditation Society in Massachusetts and
70s he's cool [ __ ] I like that book
people love the book The Four Agreements
I've read it I can't really get through
it because I think it's too baby baby
easy easy but everyone I know that I
really respect their self-help spiritual
life loves it and I'm like okay I don't
really like it that much but a lot of
people love it so maybe check that out I
guess that's all I'm going to recommend
because I think there's no topic per se
as much as it's about getting out of
your own ego don't you think everybody
and not like I have a big ego but you
noticing all right Kevin good luck with
that not having kids alright because of
you in your podcast I've started talk
therapy one more person into oh by the
way everybody by the goddamn way if you
want this therapist therapist hang on
one sec hang on one sec you guys I'm
going to I'm going to talk to you about
something really important but before I
do that I'm going to talk to myself and
return an email as I do that and I don't
know why I think that I can I can scroll
and do this at the same time but I think
I'm going to are you trying to kill that
fly this is like mr. Miyagi [ __ ] I wish
you guys could have seen what just
happened there is a fly sitting on a
crazy crazy crazy that was amazing but
probably not know the rules
okay so what was I saying oh I was
saying I'm glad this podcast is
influenced people to do therapy and
listen if you can't get your therapist
office you know aa Meazza this episode
is brought to us by our friends at talk
space that's right talk space is the
online therapy company that connects you
with a licensed therapist now here's the
deal
the therapist is not going to tell
everybody what you're telling her or him
therapy is confidential that's what I
love about therapy they can't say [ __ ]
to anybody they're not going to write
some op-ed piece about oh my client came
in and said this not allowed to that's
what's so great about therapy it's
confidential you can say whatever you
want you might just find yourself going
I don't even know I was going to say
this but blah they might ask you
questions you're like oh good question
let me think about that and then you
answer it you start rolling and you
start knowing yourself and it's great
you've got to take care of your mental
health and we all know that it can be
hard to make it to a therapist office
whether it's too expensive whether there
isn't one in your area maybe you don't
have a car maybe you're anti car but
that's why I'm always excited that we
are brought to you by talk space the
online therapy company that connects you
with a licensed therapist not just some
jackass for just 32
dollars a week you can talk about
anything politics I'm going to knowing
you and your family if your sisters
dating a prisoner whatever talk space
can help use the top space smartphone
app or website and you can text an audio
message your therapist as much as you
want and for a reasonable additional fee
you can do a video call as well so
sometimes you want to see what they look
like keep an eye on them make sure
they're not playing bejeweled blitz
while they're talking to you which why
would they do that these are licensed
therapists so don't lose sleep don't
lose your cool and don't lose out on my
special offer
top space.com slash Jen or use coupon
code Jen chieh en and you're going to
get $30 off your first month it's
basically like one week free and to show
your support for this a podcast
thank you talk space anyway so we've got
listener email here because of you and
your podcast I started talk therapy I
realize that there are some things I
need help with that I cannot do on my
own that is absolutely right but here's
the thing you are doing it on your own
they're not doing it for you you're
doing it on your own it's taken a lot of
trial and error but I found a woman I
really like and it progressed fairly
well in the few months I've been seeing
her anyway on this week's episode you
teased a listener email for next week
where someone asked when the right time
to tell someone you're dating that you
don't want kids is oh I did and then I
never got around to reading it until
just now I don't want kids and I don't
think I'll change my mind about this I
have a wonderful seven-year-old niece
and an insane two-year-old nephew my
love for other humans has been met when
I was 25 I met a man that I decided I
wanted to pursue I thought was weird
when someone says a 25 year old is a man
but I guess they are
oh I decided to tell him before our
first date that I was not interested in
having children and probably would not
want to be married I do not agree with
the outdated institution of marriage
where men own women well I see what
you're saying I'm I'm I enjoy that
knowing that some day out you know can
get on someone's health insurance here I
mean I'll totally I'll get me again
she's doing that on the first date
absolutely
well I think she said I'm not interested
in being married or having children and
then I think the I do not agree with the
outdated institution
might be just to me still all that a lot
on the first day listen I agree and I
think most men to stereotype men most
would be like fine with that but then
when you start talking that way they
don't realize that you're just saying
like I'm telling you who I am they're
like why is this person already thinking
about all this yeah and I think it can
be scary and you can seem like kind of
intense when you're doing that yeah yeah
I don't think you want to walk into a
first date going
I'm kintyre Lee set in my ways right so
because also says something about
specially when you're 25 if yeah it also
says something about who you are like or
what else is she Center weighs about see
ladies straight ladies hot take from
Erin don't do that you are married right
and your wife did not say that when you
first sat down no are you guys going to
have kids and when did you know when did
you talk about it then for the first
time was it when you were just dating
yeah definitely
but did you guys know in general like
whether it's with each other but you
were building open to kids we met on
OkCupid so it's one of the things it's
one of the criteria oh really
yeah it's like do you want [ __ ] yeah I
will see that's what I should have told
that guy too
yeah if you're on a dating website I
would assume they ask that the better
ones here not tinder is not going to say
I'm sure oh you're right that's like I
don't even know what tinder like if you
have a bio on tinder or something I
don't even know
Aaron's nodding yes because you secretly
as a tenure guys just kidding
yeah I mean would assume the quality
dating websites but a speck is that's
something you need to know but it's like
I want to say it right at first high I
want kids okay we haven't even ordered
yet
you can filter out people that are like
yes definitely filter out the people
like me these heathens I mean I'm not on
there so I'm filtered out anyway but in
general know these women that do not
want to do what the Lord wants them to
do well let's see what she says so that
I do not agree with the outdated
institution of marriage where men on
women we had a nice long talk about it
and he felt the same way I did I decide
to talk about and we both decided we
could pursue a relationship together he
had previously been in a four-year
relationship with a woman who knew he
didn't want these things and she thought
she could change her
mind it that and she couldn't and she
ended up devastated he and Ivan together
for three years
Oh like we're both wrong about what you
shouldn't say on the first date hasn't
worked out and have recently moved in
together the only thing I envy about
mothers is how they can get away with
ignoring people and not keeping in touch
because they're so busy letting Netflix
babysit while they drink venti
Frappuccino
chain-smoked and sit on Facebook on
their iPhone wait what kind of butters
are these I don't know if this makes
sense or is interesting the rest of this
email will be praise and gratitude so
you could stop reading it on air thank
you for my thank you for singing
therapies praise it has truly changed me
and my life well that's great and I feel
so much better when I leave I'm a big
fan how is doctor person's been doing I
know that you I did that last week so
you already have the answer we haven't
heard from her for a while I assume
she's too busy saving lives thanks for
reading well there you go I mean heads
up for therapy I don't know who these
mothers are drinking frappuccinos and
smoking but they sound like a disaster
even anyone who's not a mother who's
doing that it sounds I went to Starbucks
and are having a special cappuccino free
or half off between three and five and I
don't like cappuccino or iced anything
and I've been drinking this coffee since
like noon and I went in and I was like
caramel coffee no like save this thing
for between 3:00 and 5:00 I'm like I
don't want it though you might change
your mind I'm like I know I'm not it's
like a first date I was yelling I'm
never going to change my mind about
Frappuccino never it's an outdated
institution how about dating for three
years and then finally moving in that's
what they said what do you think about
that though oh you think that's too long
nowadays I feel like that phone no I
think it's great yeah okay I think it's
great but when did you move in a year I
mean I think a years someone said a year
I would be like Joel would you might
want to think about it the only reason
is like I will see I've been married so
that's why I'm like I'm not going to
move in right away but it's like I you
never know like maybe someone had a
lease or somebody like maybe they
someone really loved their place or I
don't know I think three years is I
think that
good because for me like unless we could
buy something like let's say like let's
just say they're the type of people that
sometimes when you move in with someone
you stay in the same amount of space
instead of going up to the next level so
maybe they've been saving to get like a
bigger space instead of hey move in with
me and it's now it's someone is up in my
closet
that kind of thing but I do think if
it's like it just depends on how you've
spent those three years if it's like
been super fun and you're like I just I
love you but like as long as we know
we're going to spend our life together
let's just make sure if it's like you
know those things like it's always it's
always regurgitated in like woman's
chick's looks like he finally proposes
in five years it's like well wait a
minute why why are you so excited that
someone that didn't know right away if
they wanted you finally did you know if
it has that feeling to it then no three
years is too long and you should bolt
because my sister when how long did she
my sister was oh she was a podcast shout
out my sister and her husband I think
didn't get married for ten years and
their divorce and me and my ex-husband
didn't get married for six years now I
don't know about my sister and her
husband but I know me I was definitely
well it takes year to plan a wedding but
I was definitely like scared that should
tell you something
so I knew something was awry here's a
researcher who didn't know I had a
podcast I don't want to get angry but I
might I might get angry feel free to use
my name greetings from Philly oh she
wrote that seeing you at the truck on
September 23rd that's right people I'll
be in Philadelphia at the Trocadero
Theatre on September 23rd you can get
tickets for all my shows jen kirkman
calm you guys I told you buy tickets in
advance I I get my numbers every week
some cities there is no ticket sold that
weekend I'm like what I mean every city
has tons of tickets that have already
sold but sometimes the numbers don't go
up and I get sad I guess I said because
I don't want to be scrambling in August
is my vacation month I'm thinking of
taking a little solo trip to Sedona I
don't know what I'm going to do but I'm
gonna tell you people this I don't want
to be doing press
these [ __ ] shows in September you
sell me out in September now pretend I'm
a successful female comic like all the
other ones on Netflix Ali Wong
she's a puts her tour dates on sale
sells out the day of thousand seats then
keeps adding why can't my fans do that
when it was up so September Philly
Boston Washington DC New York City
Brooklyn San Francisco Seattle Portland
Oregon in Vancouver that's where I'm
going to be in September Jen Kirkman
comm click tour dates buy those tickets
now there's tons of other cities and
tons of other months Atlanta Nashville
Asheville Durham Cincinnati Cleveland
Columbus this summer I'll be in Montreal
we're adding Toronto and we're adding
Dallas Houston and Austin so stay on
that email blast Jen Kirkman dot-com
click tour dates see the tour dates join
the email blast blah blah blah I send it
out once a week it's really written by
me and then I send it off and someone
else does all the [ __ ] so alright silly
I'm 52 never been married no kids lots
of friends and activities to happily
living alone with two cats Missy
she is I'm a librarian stop you're like
a I don't mean this in a bad way but
you're like literally like a cliche like
you go cats never been married okay what
you're a librarian to like if I wrote
you in a movie people be like alright
ease off that's like three stereotypes
and I love it I love it I love it I used
to work at a library in college before
the internet everybody and what was so
fun about that was when you started a
library card I had to type in all your
info and we had this weatherman in
Boston named dick not Dick Clark dick
Albert and dick Albert's son went to
Emerson College and he lived at home
with his dad the first year of college
and he gave me all his info and I knew
the guy you enjoyed Albert son and he's
like yeah and so I had dick Albert's
phone number and he'd always be on the
news like it's a snow day you don't have
school and my friends and I would get
drunk and prank call him and be like
dick like if it was snowing out we'd be
like dick is there going to be no school
tomorrow and he would laugh and laugh I
found out later he was a pothead so you
certainly enjoying it anyway so being a
librarian can get you access to some of
the hottest most popular weather
I'm a librarian so if the podcast ever
needs an official one or a researcher
I'm your gal you can absolutely be the
icing fund librarian researcher but I
don't know your name but that's okay
I'm a comedy nerd I know you from Paul F
Thompkins podcast drunk history your CDs
your Netflix specials your appearances
on shows like at midnight and not safe
which is why I'm embarrassed that I
found out about I seem fun through a
friend from Australia just earlier this
year now what kind of researcher are you
I was crowdsourcing on Facebook looking
for a new podcast to follow and she said
hey do you listen to Jen Kirkman Jen
Kirkman has a podcast how did I not know
about this boy was my face red
I have sense the tone for my sins by
going on a binge through all of your
podcasts in order I love you being a fan
I know
I knew I'd love them and I do but I
think the moment I really went all-in
was the first time he played Lawrence
Welk's exit music I was very close to my
late grandmother we always watch the
show together when I spent weekends at
her house I hadn't heard that music
since the last time I saw her almost 14
years ago and it instantly brought tears
to my eyes oh I know when I was little
my family used to sing good night sleep
tight and pleasant dreams do you know
let's play that free now let's make our
cry no in a good way
um do you like Hallmark Christmas movies
because if you have them black and white
can you like Hallmark Christmas movies I
might just move in with you when I'm in
Philly and stay there through the
through the UM can you hear this this
isn't the ending music but it's called
champagne time by Lawrence Welk
beautiful music to listen to
you know everyone should do on a first
date play this song in your car or if
you bring them back to your home and
just go hi let's get to know each other
more oh do you like this song okay I
find that so comforting oh my god you
know how hard it is for me to not be on
Twitter right now looking at what's
going on the FBI is rating something but
this is going to come out in like two
weeks so by the time this comes out we
might even have a new president oh oh oh
and finally the librarian did something
that I wish everybody else would do
things that other people find fun that I
do not Disney video games
I know hate video games I like bejeweled
blitz and I mention it jokingly but I
[ __ ] plant big parties televised
sports hate hate hate that - wine
tastings I've actually never been to one
but I sure like tasting wine with the
ladies and love actually oh my god I
hate that movie so not good I've tried
to watch okay my friend Chris who
actually you guys are going to get to
know him on an episode or you maybe
already did who you is here we love
those movies where it's like there's 70
famous people in it like there's one
called New Year's Eve
Delia Marshall the Garry Marshall film
and you're just like I'm on a plane I
don't look at some attractive people and
then I don't know what they're talking
about is the relationship Love Actually
I keep trying to watch it like on
airplanes and I'm like this blows it's
not good and I like Hugh Grant I think
he's charming I don't care about the
plot about him and his weird young Asian
assistant or whatever and then is that
the movie where they do the card the
cards they stand at the door and and I
like the Hillary Clinton SNL sketch that
they say spoof that wouldn't I thought
that was funny
but I don't like the I don't like the
movie I'm on your husband's best friend
and I love you that's [ __ ] gross
always that what the movies about that's
what that seems about oh it's always
about all different couples and
different things yeah some of them are
real Downers the only movie I liked it's
like cheesy rom-com while there I liked
a few but I loved my best friend's
wedding
oh I cry I like when people don't get
their way at the end but like something
it's just like nice and you're like okay
I get it she says things that I find fun
that other people don't spending time
alone organizing things oh I love to
organize research I don't know if I like
research but you do it for a living
cold weather me too going into the city
who doesn't like going into the city
you're singing how dare you I love you
know I was just in New York for six
weeks I'm going back I think by the time
you hear this I might be there I don't
know I'm going back and it was raining
the whole time I was there and I [ __ ]
loved it it's like the winter I never
got to have and everyone there was
complaining and I get it because they
have winter all the time but they're
like they were so mad at me I was like I
love it and maybe I should have just
shut the [ __ ] up but great story alright
I'm going to do one more before we part
here oh wait let me look at my phone and
make sure I've got a guest coming in do
do afraid it will bite you in the ass
that's my sister okay let's read a
shorty
this guy's crying over something okay
Aaron is the hiccups okay let's see
tarot card that was oh yeah I was doing
we're going to read about we're going to
go deep and talk about high school in
the south we're not doing it okay
someone asked the airplane mechanic how
do you know if the tires are old I
remember that one and she finally well
she responded a while ago and I'm
finally reading it hi Jan I'm just
writing to answer the question you
received from a listener regarding the
lifespan of aircraft tires well that's
kind of an interesting thing because the
life of an aircraft tire is based solely
on how it looks when the plane gets
checked over at any maintenance interval
including pre-flight inspection if the
tire is showing any sign of wear like a
gauge gouge gouge oh my god my eyesight
like a Dowager slice or even a flat spot
from a hard landing it's compared
against limits spelled out in the
aircraft manufacturer maintenance manual
generally with any type of visible
visible damage to the tire there is a
very good chance that tire is changed
out for a new one I've even seen an
instance where a new tire was installed
and after a hard land
on its first flight was changed right
out back again flying planes and keeping
them safe is an expensive gig Cheers
Connie Connie I feel like you're trying
to justify the XV room the extra room
charges in the seats well that's good to
know that you guys are on top of it
I hope Trump doesn't cut any kind of
airline mechanic Union please keep us
posted on that [ __ ] because I get
nervous everything on a plane isn't
double so even if one tire's flat
there's another right behind it yeah
no next to it I wish you were saying
yeah but what if both go what if there's
no airline mechanic Union I mean that
would be nuts we'd be all spooked I'm
reading now that they know they're not
going to let it was a first like no
laptops to like you know Middle Eastern
places and I'm like God doesn't affect
me so you know I don't care just kidding
but it's sort of and another like maybe
no laptops at all
in the cabin on international flights
like are you [ __ ] kidding but you get
you can check it that's so dumb if I was
going to bomb a plane that's how do it I
would put it in I can't even I can't
even take it
this woman is creepy gentle patient no I
think this is too long I think we're
going to break I think we're going to
end on I think we're going to end on
that I'm sorry this was 51 minutes but
you people you know what you know what
you know what somebody said hi Jen don't
use my name I'm curious what you think
of the future is female t-shirts and how
you would explain it to men who think
it's offensive because it's not
inclusive Thanks
I wouldn't explain it and I would tell
them to get a life snowflake all right
until next week have fun
[Music]
the